يروج الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان عملياته في
الضفه الغربيه جاءت عقب هجمات نفذها
فلسطينيون ضد اسرائيليين لكن في الواقع
كانت البدايه من هنا في وسط مدينه نابلس
عند مقتلت قوه من المستعربين ثلاثه شبان
فلسطينيين بطلع هذا العام
تباهت اسرائيل حينها بانتهاء ما وصفتها
بعمليه تصفيه ثلاثه من المطلوبين لكن
مرحله اخرى بدات بعدها اذ توالت عمليات
نفذها شبان فلسطينيون في قلب المدن
الاسرائيليه ومع خشيه اسرائيل من ان تنتقل
المواجهه الى هناك اطلق جيش الاحتلال
عمليه سماها كاسر الامواج في مسعا لكسر
المقاومه الفلسطينيه
فنفذ خلالها اغتيالات واعدامات واعتقالات
واقتحامات تركز معظمها في منطقه جنين
ونابلس
همم
رؤيه السياسيه امنيا كان هناك من وجهه
النظر الاسرائيليه ازدياد في العمليات
الارهابيه بتشجيع من حركه حماس وسياسيا
كان يدافع صراع الحكومه من اجل البقاء لا
سليمان مع وجود معارضه يا مهنيه كانت
تنتقدهم بعدم الرد كما يجب
كذلك شهدت القدس مواجهات عده جراء
اعتداءات جنود الاحتلال والمستوطنين
المتكرره وشهد المسجد الاقصى اقتحامات
وانتهاكات واسعه ابرزها اخلاؤه من المصلين
الفلسطينيين لتامين اقتحامات المتطرفين
اليهود
كما جنه اسرائيل عدوان اخر على غزه
استهدفت خلاله قاده حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
وممارساته ظهرت مجموعه عرين الاسود جيل
جديد من المقاومين ولد اغلبهم في
الانتفاضه الثانيه عندما اجتاحت اسرائيل
الضفه الغربيه بهدف القضاء على المقاومه
ولك سرير سرير
كان عاما ثقيلا على الفلسطينيين ووصفه
تقرير اممي بانه الاكثر دمويه في الضفه
الغربيه منذ عام 2005 ويخشى الفلسطينيون
ان يصعد الاحتلال ممارساته في ظل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده
الموصوفه بالاكثر تطرفا هذه الدوله هذه
الحكومه ستعود باسرائيل الى طور الحركه
الصهيونيه حركه اذنيه قوميه متطرفه ما
سيحدث هو ان السياسات ستصبح اكثر علنيا
اتجاه فلسطين
المصادره وعمليات الدم والاعتداء على
الحقوق بما في ذلك تغيير الوضع القائم في
المسجد الاقصى
ومع اعلان هذه الحكومه بدات فئه اسرائيليه
تعبر عن خشيتها من تطرف الحكومه لا سياسيا
بالاجتماعيا ودينيا
تشير قراءه سياسيه فلسطينيه وحتى
اسرائيليه الى ان هذه الحكومه ستقود الى
مزيد من التصعيد بما قد يؤدي الى تفجر
الاوضاع فيما يرى الفلسطينيون انها ستنفذ
السياسات التي اتبعتها الحكومه السابقه
لكن بشكل علني اكثر
الجزيره مدينه القدس